a
[Música]
ah
el sobrepeso y la obesidad afectan cada
vez más a los más pobres y cada vez más
a los niños y niñas pobres es una
obesidad combinada con malnutrición
asociada al consumo de alimentos grasos
y azucarados que suelen ser más baratos
es un fenómeno mundial que se repite en
argentina según un estudio de 2019 del
ministerio de salud y desarrollo social
de este país realizado sobre poblaciones
de bajos ingresos el 29 3% de niños y
niñas de entre 2 y 5 años de edad es
clave para el desarrollo son obesos o
tienen sobrepeso y la pobreza está
creciendo en argentina de acuerdo con
estadísticas oficiales en el primer
semestre de 2020 el 40,9 por ciento de
los argentinos eran pobres casi 2
millones de personas más que en el
semestre anterior y entre los menores de
15 años la pobreza alcanzaba al 56 3 por
ciento de la población
[Música]
en brasil el sobrepeso y la obesidad
infantil son problemas de salud más
comunes de lo que se imagina aunque
todavía no se ha hecho ningún estudio
sobre la relación entre la obesidad
infantil y los ingresos familiares de
los brasileños según datos del instituto
brasileño de geografía y estadística
casi el 11 por ciento de los niños
brasileños padecen obesidad y las tasas
empeoren en el país con no se trata de
animal entre 5 y 9 años el 30 por ciento
tenían sobrepeso el 9 por ciento tiene
obesidad y el 5 por ciento tiene
obesidad severa en un intento por
advertir sobre los riesgos de la
obesidad infantil y sus crecientes tasas
de embarazo y el ministerio de la salud
lanzó en agosto de este año una guía de
alimentación infantil con sugerencias e
informaciones nutricionales que busca
mejorar los hábitos alimenticios de las
familias y la relación entre los niños y
la comida
[Música]
el sobrepeso y la obesidad infantil
están directamente relacionados con la
clase social de los hogares este esta es
la principal conclusión del informe que
presentó la semana pasada el ministro de
consumo alberto garzón que se basó en el
estudio de más de 16.000 casos de niñas
y niños de entre 6 y 9 años que se
realizó a lo largo de 2019 el estudio
muestra como entre las familias entre
los hogares con rentas más bajas
concretamente el istu el estudio la
sitúa por debajo de los 18 mil euros
ingresados anualmente los niños se
tienen más problemas de sobrepeso y de
obesidad en concreto alrededor de un 23
2% de ellos tiene problemas de obesidad
y un 47% problemas de sobrepeso ambos
índices caen más de 10 puntos cuando los
comparamos con los niños y niñas que
provienen de familias con rentas más
altas esto es según el estudio con
rentas de más de 30 mil ingresos euros
ingresados anualmente y según las
razones de esta importante disparidad el
estudio señala principalmente l
acceso a realizar distintos tipos de
actividades extraescolares y actividades
deportivas y por otro lado también
evidentemente el acceso a distintos
tipos de oferta de restauración siendo
la más económica la oferta de la llamada
comida rápida
[Música]